what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today from new rock stars black panther
2 wakanda forever trailer Easter eggs
and breakdown John how's it going good
I'm looking forward to this how are you
I'm doing good leave a like to leave a
damn like leave that like button let's
get to it
[Music]
welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of
everything you missed in the new trailer
for Black Panther wakanda Forever both
this trailer and the Comic-Con trailer
in July were edited by the super
talented Andrew Higley to some amazing
music and hegloo is actually kind enough
to shout me out on Twitter so I'm gonna
do my best to take his challenge
for the hidden layers of meaning
everything we hear everything we see
everything everyone's wearing a couple
signings of additional black panther
suits some Clues I'm sorry Andrew it's
not your fault but I did find them I
don't know how but I found them let's
take a cue from Riri Williams and let's
go
during his funeral ceremonial March all
the wakandans are wearing white which as
we saw in the 2018 film is their color
of mourning Ramona holds shuri's hand to
comfort her while shuri for now remains
hooded the way her character in this
trailer is masked look I don't want to
kick this video off we're getting
political right away
but I'm going to those memes going
around Sherry in the Black Panther suit
that are saying oh now she wants to wear
a mask that's some hilarious stuff I
don't care what political party you
belong to a plus Internet it's Universal
it's Universal her earrings look like
tusk their horns maybe claws or fangs of
a giant Panther probably not real bone
taken from any living animal like the
wakandan Rhinos because shuri would
never they are Marching toward this
garden region of wakanda with a gate
flanked by Stone carvings of two people
on the left that's bashenga founder of
wakanda the first black panther to the
right is a female figure who might be
his wife or his sister either way or
foreshadowing to the Black Panther
Legacy moving on to a female figure
close to the original black
panthers at their feet may be
representing Bost and segment this would
be the Royal Cemetery the necropolis may
be a representation of that green belt
that tashallah referenced in Civil War
in my culture death is not the end it's
stepping off a point you reach out with
both hands and bust yes that's right yes
forever meanwhile Neymar obtains a mural
depicting Google Khan The Feathered
Serpent deity from Mayan mythology the
way the Black Panther is an avatar of
the wakandan panther deity of Boston
Neymar seems to be an avatar of kukul
Khan Ryan coogler and his team are using
real world influences to create a
fictional mythology not to perfectly
adapt any actual real world mythology
but really the way boss is inspired by
the Egyptian feline deity of bastet in
segment yeah you know that's something
I'm noticing about both of these
trailers especially when it comes to
something we don't shout out enough we
often shout like production design as
sort of a general broad term I really
want to credit like the makeup
department on what they've been doing
with this film especially because the
first one was bringing a life like
African culture influences and now
you're bringing a life like Aladdin lion
culture influences Spanish culture
influences fused into this so I think
it's like really beautiful to behold of
what they're doing the same way that you
in the first movie Saw the wakanan
culture and everything that inspires it
from the outside I love that we're also
now gonna see the Atlantean culture that
way and you get just as much sort of awe
and inspiration from the outside as you
did before taking these real world
things to create something new a
close-up of sharing a little later shows
that she has ceremonial white face paint
dots on her cheeks her nose and her brow
that almost exactly yeah similar to the
mask and the Black Panther mask revealed
at the end of the trailer back in that
cave Neymar is painting this mural in an
aquatic cave that he must have access to
now as a mutant he can live both
underwater and on land his skin is human
colored because he is half human born to
a human sea captain though his ears are
pointed helping him paint is this blue
hand I'm assuming this is the hand of
the blue skin partner namora they are
using paint and a palette made from a
bisected shell and Nemours such a great
detail section in the shape of a heart
this section actually comes back in the
cutout of vibranium that River hammers
out oh neat armor now the music
throughout this trailer is an amazing
amazing track called Never Forget by
sompa the great featuring Chef 87 Tio
Nason and nuwanje Sanford the great is a
Zambian singer and rapper this is a
tribute to a genre called zamrock check
out yesterday's reaction for a breakdown
of what that is but the opening words of
this song are who took a fabric made
that [ __ ] Classic this is simply the
Great's way of reclaiming fashion and
culture as having roots in her Homeland
but in this context it reminds us that
the Black Panther mask and armor were a
vibranium weed physically woven and
constructed by one person and that
person is shuri she is the one who took
this Fabric and made this [ __ ] classic
sure he crosses her arms in the wakandan
salute right over left and I love her
hand tattoo looking like interconnected
vibranium atoms reminding us of her
engineering insights in Infinity War the
structure is polymorphic right we had to
attach each neuron non-sequentially why
didn't you just reprogram the synopsis
to work collectively because we didn't
think of it I'm sure you did your best
you know there's something I gotta point
out that I find very fascinating with
the development of black panther you
know in a time in a day in Angel we're
constantly hearing about virtually what
culture people are always spewing and
shouting all the time right there's
something that seems like pretty
accepting of Fury taking up the black
man I'm sure there's that crowd that I
really is not happy about it sure there
is I don't really hear too much of it of
an outcry or an upheaval Roar of why
because I think it just lines up I
imagine that even if Chadwick Boseman
was still with us that eventually at one
point Sherry might actually Don the
Black Panther costume because with the
comics however it just lines up with the
way the movie is and who her character
is so it's pretty cool to see that
people aren't people aren't supposed to
ignore all that stuff just to get
outraged because of the sake of getting
outrageous yeah Namor has this
interesting line saying only the most
broken people can be great leaders
beautiful life this has got to be advice
that he's giving either sure
are one of the women of wakanda because
if he was talking to one of his or
himself in the mirror he's speaking that
my language John cuerta said that he had
to learn for this film where to reveal
that name is probably the villain of
this movie but rather more of an
antagonist or an anti-hero he told
Empire magazine Latin Americans are
always bad guys in Hollywood movies but
now we're the heroes or an anti-hero in
this instance getting told Entertainment
Weekly maybe the most important twist in
the character is that he's not a selfish
person he's taking care of a community
he's not an individualist he's part of a
tribe the shot from the first trailer
returns
lettering translating to the panther
king forever lives in us and rests with
the ancestors a wide shot shows Neymar
descending to the throne of his kingdom
the kingdom called talalo Khan it's an
Aztec afterlife for those who die from
drowning or lightning or diseases
associated with the rain deity now
another afterlife production we're
calling it a Mayan realm but it's not
it's an Aztec realm but again this is
all a fictional mythology pulling from
several real
Khan isn't just an ocean realm it's a
realm accessed by any water-based source
which makes Namor and his people from
Slidell Khan more dangerous wherever you
are in land because they can get you
from any body of water deep enough to
drown in Oscar oh that's why um Hannah
beechler is back for the sequel and she
said for these underwater shots she took
visual inspiration from Steven
Spielberg's jaws and close encounters to
the Third Kind as well as Jack Kirby
images right here with a giant shark
yeah
in this blight like the blighty light
emitted by the spaceship in Close
Encounters if you look closely at that
shark Jawbone it has been carved with
Mayan figures and its teeth look like
they are made from vibranium oh neat you
know what I hope this movie gives us
because I remember when uh Aquaman came
out and and there was all that imagery
of like them riding sharks and then
sharp and rolls and stuff I feel like we
didn't get enough of that so I think
it'd be really cool if we did see some
like underwater action of like them
riding animals and them going we've got
like live action animals fighting each
other in the wakanda battlefield and the
first one let's get some underwater
animals going at it now too yeah let's
make up for the canceled trench movie
with this movie please let's get some
shark with vibranium teeth that's what I
need and then we can have vibranium
submarines and a whole vibranium just
underwater
Nemer that's my name swallow Khan has
its own supply of vibranium maybe a
chunk that broke off from that original
meteorite and it's likely why this human
Expedition is trying to get Neymar's
headpiece is a feathered serpent
matching the appearance of cuckoo Khan
costumer Ruth e Carter is also returning
and she says she had to test these
feathered outfits by submerging them in
water testing these pieces so that they
would look like wow holy crappy channel
the editing of this trailer sinks with
Neymar Lori and his staff so that it
looks like it is he who is jabbing
Aquarius spear in the clay of the
wakanda throne room claiming it for
himself which is fitting because right
when this spear hits the trailer shifts
to rapper Chef 187's break in the song
these lyrics translate to this lyrics
referencing wearing the belt and the
phrase all kingdoms and kingdoms belong
to us now if we aligned state of the
great with the voice of shuri in this
trailer Chef 87 would be the voice of
the Challenger Namor cutting the promo
demanding the belt defending his kingdom
by demanding a second Kingdom as also
belonging to him it's the most
deliberate this movie really seems like
it's going to be doing that beautiful
sequel thing that last of us two sequel
thing because if you had like killmonger
in the first one where eventually you
would learn of what his pass really is
is and then you would grow to sort of
you know empathize for what this journey
is that he's on whereas here I feel like
we're probably going to be cutting back
and forth a little bit more where you're
gonna see how much namor's journey and
whatever the life is that's going on
with him and his people mirrors to a
certain extent what's going on with the
people in wakanda before they perhaps
might find some type of understanding
and Common Ground by the end that some
people complained about how killmonger
went to sort of like full body at the
end of the finale before we had that
beautiful speech of the laments before
he dies I don't feel like it's going to
go in that similar trajectory it looks
like this is going to be a real parallel
of a story we see more shots of the land
dwellers ocean mix but Edition deep sea
divers and armed contracted soldiers
never a good sign these divers have a
creepy Shadow darting across frame in
front of them the ship is an Enviro plus
this whole vessel that assists in Marine
Environmental Services like oil spills
but these humans are likely threatening
the people of talocon who we see
climbing aboard and raiding the ship
there's a woman who retreats to a
helicopter on the pad shooting at them
how dare this woman but I believe this
is actress
voice actor who voiced Natasha Romanov
in episodes that's right
and Poison Ivy and HBO Max is Harley
Quinn she's a fairly big name and this
film might have something major plan for
her we see the original a lot of
live-action work too Mountain tribe High
land to get away from the flooding but
this shots VFX have been sneakily edited
since the July version of the trailer ah
bring some heavy crates with them what
are these are they supplies vibrations
still working on it could contain the
components of her new suit because we
know that a new version of the suit will
be unveiled in the snowy mountain
location surrounded by its tribes
[Music]
saying his people do not call him a
general or King they call him cuckoo con
the feather serpent God killing him will
risk Eternal War I love how animated
Winston Duke is as a Storyteller here
and one also wonders how umbaku knows
this information about Neymar to brief
the others his words make it sound like
name or as the Avatar of a deity Bears
some immortality or Untouchable status
like killing them could unleash some war
between the Gods like the fight we saw
between kanchu and Ahmet and Moon Knight
I don't know I think it's more personal
than that I think mbaku knew of a secret
pact between t'challa and Neymar as
Bella
both of them pacifists struggling to
keep peace among the more aggressive
factions of Their Kingdoms for t'challa
that was probably in Baku but for Neymar
that would be atuma so umbaku is now
warning if you kill Neymar you're
actually opening his shark Jawbone
Throne to an even more hostile successor
oh [ __ ] didn't do anything about that
undersea earthquake oh damn jeez oh I
love that I love this whole secret
packed idea that just makes it that much
more personal of a tale and why we
haven't seen Neymar well that just
answers so much it's got to credit that
theory right there oh yeah because that
just answers so much of why it hasn't
been dealt with or why akoye was like
kind of dismissive over that yeah yeah
like it adds so much Mystique to be like
oh they already have a pre-existing
thing that the rest of us don't know
about and are now gonna have to
intimately deal with it kind of strikes
me that name or might need help with
something and that they refuse to it and
that's why they start battling it out in
some way as opposed to their King's dead
let's go attack yeah yeah and said hey
maybe you should be sympathetic to our
planet oh no we again see Neymar's
underwater birth where you can already
see the little wings on his feet
overtime to Flap him into the Golden
City and later shots show that he is
floating over to the wakandan throne
room where ramonda and Riri Williams are
staring him down as he flips up his
Spirit who throw at them this looks like
a blow that's gonna be pretty hard for
Emoto to evade unless Riri or shuri
might have equipped her with some
vibranium nanotech to very quickly emit
from that necklace adornment yes I think
we all really need to see Angela Bassett
in her own vibranium suit she certainly
earned one we see more shots that was
shown at d23 French soldiers raiding a
wakanda Outreach Center in Mali trying
to plunder its vibranium but scientists
reveal themselves as covert members of
the dorm Elijah including Michaela Cole
as Anika who the comics is a former door
milaje who leaves and forms a new team
called the midnight Angels who in one
storyline try to kill Dr Doom for
stealing wakanda vibranium or doctor oh
my god dude it's what yes that is less
more weight to the theory than Dr Doom
is the one orchestrating this in some
way or somehow maneuvering strings
around that would make it happen oh come
on that's right that's like really I
mean what a reveal that could be easily
we've been off out here just fighting a
different Threat all along see another
door milage slice the guns using their
spirits to deflect bullets and take down
these soldiers d23 footage actually ends
but the door melangee marching these
soldiers into the U.N to shame the
French delegate who Ramona is verbally
sparring with name or the other people
from Silicon swim one of the background
rides in Orca impressive I could
everyone stay on the inflatable pool
raft orcas name or confronts those are
harder tropical beats which might be the
same Beach that we saw Nakia on with
that Mayan pyramid meaning this might be
terp belonging to Silo Khan Okoye stabs
her spear through her car one marked
with Illinois plates so this must be
part of her recruitment or extraction of
Riri Williams who begins her story in
Chicago a quick shot shows okoye's car
someone on a motorcycle and Riri soaring
above them both with her Iron Heart
armor I assume this is her Mark 1 armor
more shots of wakanda flooding an attack
from swallow Khan inspired by The
Avengers vs X-Men comic when Namor
possessed by the Phoenix Force actually
floods wakanda Ryan coogler told weekly
the power of water and waves at a deeper
symbolic weight to this movie with the
passing of Chadwick Boseman saying
there's that idea of grief and intense
emotion feeling like it comes in waves
sometimes a wave can take you away where
you lose control of it you think you're
in control but the water can always
remind you that you are not I mean yeah
that's just such a beautiful sentiment
because like that's the main thing that
I think all of us are sort of gathering
from both the trailers and sort of
commenting it a little bit in the last
trailer reaction was that so much of
this movie seems to be about grief and
the unity that comes the strength that
comes from bonding together after grief
because yes some there's pain that it
gets Unleashed from grief but at the
same time there can be a beautiful
unexpected strength that comes from
uniting together under the pain of grief
as well those waves of catharsis I think
it's a really beautiful sentiment and I
feel like the trailer is the main thing
they are really evoking is that pain
with a slight glimmers of light at the
end of the tunnel one brief shot shows
name more slamming down his spear if you
look closely behind him on the right
there is someone in a black panther suit
fighting him or protecting whoever name
oh [ __ ] based on the silhouette as this
black panther jumps that looks like the
new female suit but in the shot of the
Mask maybe it's just the resolution oh
there's no white dot stuff you can
really make out any of those signature
dots on the mask in fact it also has
pronounced silver eyebrows that don't
really appear on the female mask at the
end of the trailer so this might be a
completely
theory that we might actually see
multiple black panther suits in this
movie maybe multiple female black
panther suits give it to a koi give it
to Nokia 2 and Ramona give it to them
all and Embark you throw one at him as
well yeah that's just your token one guy
give him one suit that way people don't
completely lose their minds I don't know
it could just be a lack of you know
they're still probably doing digital
shows I was gonna say if they change
that one shot maybe they just need to
change this other shot yeah wow that'd
be crazy if they sort of snuck that in
that's kind of crazy they kept that in
there when this is after this is before
the reveal shot in the trailer whoa I
don't know it's pretty intentional
they've had to have done that
intentionally yeah to give a little clue
I feel like probably another black
panther it wouldn't be here by mistake
yeah Neymar uses his name ankle Wings to
Dart Upward at wakanda aircraft that
fire on him zigzagging in a way that
looks like he's hopping across platforms
like an American Ninja Warrior and an
obstacle course mbaku must be part of
this defense we see him jumping from the
water down at Neymar in the previous
trailer and in this trailer we see him
thumping his chest like a badass looks
like there also be an aerial chase
between Riri Williams and her new Iron
Heart suit I think she's going to build
a Mark II armor in series live on
wakanda because there's an overhead shot
showing Riri working on that fragmented
floor pattern that is unique to the lab
this Mark II armor has Wing appendages
that pop out the back and boot mounted
thrusters similar to Tony Stark's Mark
50 armor that he used to catch up to
Spider-Man and infinity War we even see
reread and Iron Man style heads up
display close-up her head suspended
surrounded by her glowing interface the
text around her face reads max power and
there's a radar showing her chasing
someone and I love the coloring of all
this Tony's on the details
a bright red Tuma leaps out of a river
up at Okoye on a bridge again any body
of water anywhere poses a threat from
slalocon Nakia such as an intricate
pattern of green
green is the color of the wakandan River
tribe but these blue pieces of her top
are patterned to look like a Central
Lake of wakanda in a literal river that
snakes through the green land of the
country this could represent Nakia being
a river that links wakanda to the ocean
dwellers of swallow Khan there's a very
Jaws
merch releases tell us that this is
called the Royal Sea leopard and we know
it's going to be the setting of a major
Maritime battle the final shot of this
trailer shows the New Black Panther
dropping out of a hatch actually this is
the same hatch t'challa dropped out
having been the First Act of the 2018
film but now they drop into the snowy
mountain region of the Jabari tribe and
as they land purple energy courses up
through the legs to show the shock
absorption remember this is the
technology shuri invented with her
sneakers sneaker that she is seen
wearing in promo posters
Shockwave that marble has been ending in
the letters of Marvel Studios in the
opening Fanfare is of most of their
recent titles at least the ones ever
since Chadwick Boseman passed and the
latest theatrical release added a
specific shot to the opening montages
showing t'challa doing his handshake
with his little sister who do we read
this as a passing of a torch now the
same suit that ended the July trailer
with the gold trimming on the Cavs the
open Panther mouths on the arms like the
hand weapons that shuri was operating in
the 2018 film and now we can clearly see
this is a slender female figure that
truly does match the silhouette of
Leticia Wright that plus the dots
matching her face paint does really make
us think this is shuri it's kind of
crazy that the trailers are just sort of
show that maybe they thought like people
are already putting it together there's
already leaks coming out that it is I
didn't know for sure well I know a lot
of boys likely yeah and it's also
motivated by things directly in the
previous movie so in some ways I can
imagine them sitting around going it
can't be that much of a surprise can it
yeah however you may find the music
staying familiar here
this is the same music Ryan cooglers
used for the dorm Elijah oh so it could
be okay
so that might be a clue pointing to this
being a koi or some other door melange
like an AKA but I know this music might
also just refer to the women of wakanda
in general now if you look closely
behind this figure there are a few
Jabari tribesmen but also a red cloaked
or melange who might be Okoye or AO it's
kind of hard to tell but as the camera
pans up you can see behind that Red
Cloak is a tech to up suited leg with
similar oh
[Music]
everyone get it tucked up
this movie could present a whole team of
women who are all working together to
try to carry the legacy of t'challa by
the way I'm still a fan of that theory
that shuri could synthetically reproduce
the heart-shaped herb and then Venture
into the ancestral plane to resurrect
killmonger who was buried at Sea I'm
just still looking for evidence for it
in this footage I love this trailer so
much I can't wait to break down this
movie when it comes out in November you
can follow me on Tick Tock Instagram and
Twitter at eavos follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye fantastic work Vos and
editors and graphics people in every
Department here it's incredibly great
job putting the studio together yeah
incredibly well researched uh thank you
so much I learned so much from that that
is wild this is wild stuff man so many
great details
um guys subscribe to new rock stars
follow ya Voss on Twitter you can
subscribe to us but before we end this I
want to give a patreon
Adelia Chamberlain Adelia look right now
shmodown has ended and I know you had a
real important vital
spot and helping to further the
expansion of the schmodown Legacy and
you put together some wonderful articles
interviews and you helped out with
behind the scenes and certain things so
I'm sorry that time has passed but I
want you to know that your work is not
overlooked and that passion and
enthusiasm can be carried on to other
aspects of your life so I would just
redirect that emotion and find something
else to convert that energy into that
way you can further expand your future
into something even more beautiful and
meaningful and make even more
connections than you already did before
so thank you for all you've contributed
thank you for being here for so long for
being just such a sweetheart of a human
being
and uh I look forward to seeing what
more you end up being a part of in the
future love you dear
[Music]